πρεί να μη σεβοηθήσει κάποιοι λένει ότι στις ευροεκλογές η παρουσία του φιδία περιόρησε την
άνοδον του ελάμ ναι θα μπορούσε κάποιος δατοισχυριστεί αλλά τα αυτό χρονα στο ψηφοδέλτιων του
ελάμ υπήρχαν δύωσει στημικές προσωπικότετες ο μάριος οπελεκάνως και ο πάπλος οιοάνου ο πρωίν χρηρματο
δικονομικός επιλήτροπος αράδεν είναι όλα τα κόμματα αδή υπάρχουν καινούρ για κόμματα το ελάμ αξίζει
των κόπον να το ψάξει κάποιος ναδή πώς ε λειτούργησε πόσο διαφορετικά ελιτούργη ε από
τα παραδοσιακακόμματα πόσο είνεδοκή μας εν κάτι καινούργιων και του βγήκε αρά είναι μεγάλη πληγή
του συναγερμού το λάμ νομίζω ότι μεγάλη πληγή του συναγερμού όπως και του ακέλ πρώταπόλενει
απορχί δηλαδή το ότι ο κόσμος τους τους γυρίζει την πλάτη και πρωτημα να κάτισει
στω καναπέντου παρά να συμπί τον κόπο μα σηκωθεί να πάει να ψηφήσεις στης εκλογίας
σίγουρα ηστη δεξιά υπάρχει πιλογί κάτι πουδεπλέπουμε να υπάρχει εδώ και δεκαϊτίεση στην αριστερά δηλαδή
εκεί και ανυπάρχει εντελός μεγάλη ανομβρία δηλαδή το εκε υπάρχει ξηρασία ουσιαστικά μέεκτός από το
αγέλ δεν υπάρχει τίποτε άλλο και δε φαίνεται να υπάρχουν και οι διαίτερες κοινήσεις αν
θεωρίσουμε ότι το βόλτο παίλνει στην κέντρο αριστερά που πιστευωτικά που εκεή ιδιολογικά είναι αφυ
πολλά στελέχει του προέρχονται από το από το αγγελ δεντο έντο ξερωτητο αλλά οι ηθέσεις
τους τον κύπριακό ε κοινωνικά ζητήματα κάποιος θα τους ετοποθετούσε στην κέντρου αριστερά παρα στην
κεντροδεξία ίσως ενηπρώτη φορά που θα δούμε κάποιον ανταγωνισμόν απέναντης το αγέλ θεωρίσω ότι η
υποψήφει του κοσιοκτώ είναι αυτή τρεις που ακούμε καθημερινά και τους βλέπουμε να είναι συνέχειας
εκδηλώσεις ι διοσιαστικά ι ανήτα δημητρίου ο νυμπροεδρος ονίκος χριστοδουλίδης και στων ωρίζοντα φαίνεται και
ο δησίας μεχαλή της οποίος